barack obama is mocking republicans over
their concerns about teaching critical
race theory in schools take a look
there are certain right-wing media
venues for example
that monetize and capitalize on stoking
the fear and resentment
of a white population that is witnessing
a changing america you would think
with all the public policy debates that
are taking place right now
that you know the republican party would
be
engaged in a significant debate lo and
behold the single
most uh important issue to them
apparently right now is critical race
theory
who knew that that was the threat to our
republic
and fox news contributor leo tyrell
calling out the former president for his
rhetoric
he's the last person on earth that
should be promoting
the critical race theory here's a man if
he's oppressed
he became president of the united states
when you
promote a theory of hate that
specifically
targets a particular group of people i.e
being white that is a discussion and
affects every american in this country
who
in this world oppress president obama
he became president greg give us your
take on
the obama interview um that was a really
stupid comment by former president obama
he's basically insulting people for
actually understanding
a a critical curriculum he would prefer
you to be ignorant of it to be a low
information
person but all of what he should be
saying wow i'm pretty impressed that
these people
know this stuff it's a you know and also
he makes this mistake where he says you
know
in the part of the interview he talks
about how his daughters are saying
canceled culture is out of control or
it's not good
and then he says crt is you know a
harmless he doesn't see the connection
between the two the critical race theory
helps create the cancel culture by
saying that everybody
everybody who isn't non-white is an
oppressor and therefore
must be canceled and and finally how
does he not get
that education is actually way more
important
than anything he just talked about
whether it was climate change
or anything his priorities are all
contingent on
solving uh education which is basically
the pyramid base for everything else i
mean
if you look we talked about crime in the
a block
if you look at people that are killed by
police you can trace it almost all the
way back
to their education what how was their
education it would be the root cause it
would be the root thank you dana the
root cause
a little bring it back what did you make
of that um comment that he had
you know the uh i i'm not sure that the
president
is is uh is prospering in his
post-presidency he does i mean i'm not
talking financially
i i mean in terms of the impact when he
comes on you know he's going to be
mellow and laid back and cooler than you
and smarter than you and uh you know i i
i watch him and it's almost like i've
heard it before even if i've never heard
it before
in terms of critical race theory though
and i think that
people here and the network are too
sensitive
about critical race theory and not
sensitive enough to me
about the history of if you were a black
kid
going to public school in the south in
the 1950s 1960s
what was your curriculum jefferson davis
was a great guy stonewall jackson is the
hero of heroes
robert e lee is the next to jesus you
know
contemporary society sorts these things
out now it's all the rage a year or two
from now
you're not going to have white kids
looking at each other hating themselves
it's not
you know this will even out i want us
you know
why are we so freaked out about
differences what what happened to these
because it's racist
the old concept the old concept of uh
we're in this together you know well it
doesn't i mean that's kind of
all right katie like we are all in this
together well
i'm not going to insult all the parents
in loudoun county in fairfax county who
have been leading the charge
against critical race theory and they
are a diverse group of parents
who who grew up with the legacy of
martin luther king jr saying we want to
judge
our kids and each other by the content
of their character not by the color of
their skin
and they have very publicly stated that
the critical race theory
a curriculum that they are seeing their
kids come home with does the opposite of
that and it's teaching
their kids and their kids of their
neighbors who live on the same street as
them and the kids that they play
baseball with or sports with at school
to hate each other based on their skin
color
it's really not even about american
history it's about looking at someone in
a hierarchy of skin color and saying
because you're
lighter than i am or because you're
white you you have oppressed me even
though you've never even done that you
know
you are you are a product of the sin of
the people who came before you despite
having
zero or anything to do with the history
of the country and it lacks a ton of
context when it comes to
the progress that the country has made
and so the bottom line is parents who
are fighting critical race theory
don't want their kids to grow up looking
at their fellow peers
and saying i'm going to judge you based
on
your skin color and determine whether i
should oppress you you should impress me
or whether we can move forward together
as americans and so they're just worried
about their kids growing up to hate each
other as a result of the curriculum so
as usual president obama doesn't have
all the facts on what critical race
theory actually is
final word jesse obama's trying to put
out a fire because
critical race theory is really hurting
democrats average moms and dads
are livid about it what they're hearing
back from school it's insidious it's
pollution of the brain geraldo
i want graphic detail what about the
history
i want it all out there for us to learn
i don't want psychological warfare
on a 13 year old who's trying to make it
through the day
and that's what this is they're trying
to hurt their brain and divide the
country
and people are game to it they get it
and they've rejected it and obama's
trying to minimize it
and tell the rest of the democrats hey
use this line
try this line out because he's trying to
help him democrats aren't doing great
right now
you're right it was like everybody asked
like how what can we do about
the country being so polarized well then
the parents i think
in this case like the parents are kind
of stepping up on this one hey sean
hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else